Stardust dealer was killed last night by
a vigilant reports of my death have been
greatly exaggerated physiology changed
head strength and I don't think he feel
pain if Samson is building an army again
I'm gonna need mine soon uh-oh
is that just your thing
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so we got an
arrow SummerSlam trailer they're
basically doing like their version of a
SummerSlam rematch Stephen Amell vs.
Stardust it's the thing that they
created this t-shirt for so let's break
it down so this is the coolest thing
ever so if you have no idea whose
Stardust is or you don't watch WWE
Stephen Amell is like a lifelong WWE fan
so they invited him to participate in
SummerSlam one year like they started is
this thing with Stardust who is Cody
Rhodes the character that you're seeing
in the trailer here called Samson so
what happened is is last year they hyped
up a wrestling rivalry that culminated
in Stephen Amell fighting him during
SummerSlam Stephen Amell won but then
before they could have a rematch in the
ring
Cody Rhodes retired from the WWE so he
had to leave the Stardust name behind so
because in real life they're Bros and
Cody is so good at doing stunts like the
types of stunts they do on arrow
you know just hardcore wrestling
takedowns they thought you know hey why
don't we do an episode let's find an
opportunity so they wrote this character
for him you also may have recognized all
the Easter eggs for their real-life
wrestling conflict in this trailer like
the drug that they manufacture and deal
is called Stardust so Cody deals in
Stardust he's putting a team together he
can't feel pain just like wrestlers seem
like they can't feel pain just
unbelievable takedowns that they just
seemingly walk away from and even more
than that you look at some of the stunts
it looks like stunts that you would see
inside the wrestling ring so like I'll
play this in slow motion you can kind of
see like how crazy this is going to be
the studs will be like even crazier than
they normally are like the big takedowns
and it looks like it's going to
culminate in a giant tag-team match team
versus team like team wrestling if
you've never watched wrestling some
times during big matches they'll have
like one dude versus another dude
they'll fight his friend will tag in
so sometimes it'll be two-on-one then
another guy from the other team will tag
in and you just have like this battle
royale in the ring so it looks like
that's what they're building to in this
episode but the thing about him not
feeling pain reminds me of Stephen Amell
talking
about their match so what happens is if
you don't watch wrestling
most of it is choreographed within a
certain degree like they plan a little
bit about how the match is going to go
but they still have to do those moves so
if one of the wrestlers messes up and
hits someone the wrong way or like if
you're getting slammed on the mat or
flipped over and you land the wrong way
you can really hurt yourself really
badly so Stephen Amell said he
accidentally punched Kody full in the
face like not in the wrestling way that
wrestlers punch each other and Kody just
just did not show it at all so I feel
like the bit about him not being able to
feel pain in the trailer is just a joke
about that like wrestlers look like they
don't feel pain but for those you that
are asking I don't like you know does he
look like Grundy we know what's going on
here he gets dipped in chemicals Joker
style comes out looking like he's undead
so as far as I know he's not supposed to
be any particular comic book character
but hopefully he's still alive at the
end of this episode and they just throw
him in prison so that he can come back
in a future episode and they can have
another rematch just like a fun episode
but this is just kind of intended to be
like arrowverse SummerSlam so if you've
seen wrestling you probably pick up on a
lot of Easter eggs during the episode
but if not it's just going to be like a
really fun Throwdown where they just
beat the [ __ ] out of each other mr.
terrific is wearing his T face paint so
we'll see that the team itself is
working together a little bit better and
here's the other thing too this is kind
of crazy so Marc Guggenheim himself
showrunner is listed on the cast for the
episode as if he's appearing in the
episode somewhere in the name they list
for him is Guggenheim ship so I don't
know if he's going to be doing something
funny or if you're just going to be
appearing in the background or I'll have
a speaking part but keep your eyes
peeled for Marc Guggenheim to appear in
the episode but get hype let me know
like what are you more excited about
just the idea of a SummerSlam rematch or
just seeing all the crazy stunts that
they do because it definitely looks like
they tried to do some wrestling style
takedowns but you know it'd be really
awesome is is when we get to the four
night crossover like once Oliver finally
accepts Supergirl if he teaches her some
crazy wrestling takedowns so that she
can use that on some of the other
super-powered villains that she fights
that's
the one problem with like Superman
Supergirl characters that are
essentially gods you don't need to be a
good fighter because you're so strong
you just so damaged
that's why Superman during Man of Steel
got his ass handed to him by the other
Kryptonians by Zod and his followers
because he's super strong but he's never
fought a day in his life so he's
terrible when it comes to fighting
someone of equal strength so wouldn't it
be awesome though if Supergirl learned
some badass wrestling takedown moves to
use during future episodes but there
aren't that many villains that she could
do that with like most of the villains
she'll probably go up on her show won't
be so much strong as they are smart or
have ways to disable her powers so like
you have metallo kryptonite you don't
need to be a good fighter when you're
metallo because you could basically just
SAP all for strength but it's going to
be an awesome week so we have metallo
Superman on Monday then we have Jesse
quick on Tuesday then we have Stardust
vml rematch on Thursday and then we have
just a society on Thursday so I'll just
remind everyone with the DC scheduled is
for all the shows when I post that
Supergirl video on Monday night but if
you didn't see the Jesse quick video I
just posted there is a new round of the
DC giveaway going on right now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so
next video should be spider-man
homecoming I'm gonna try and finish the
rest of Luke Cage so a bunch of Marvel
stuff posting on Sunday everybody be
sure to wear your SummerSlam t-shirts on
Wednesday so while you guys wait for my
next video you can click here for my
Jesse quick flash trailer and you can
click here for this week's episode of
the arrow
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you